[Music]
[Applause]
kurt warner the hall of famer works for
the nfl network and westwood won he was
on the call last night of course the
super bowl mvp a couple of times
kurt handled the color commentary
cowboys packers last night with kevin
harlan on westwood one what did you
think was going to happen last night
kurt
not what i saw i mean i felt like the uh
the champs were going to come out and
uh i don't want to say dominate because
i felt like the cowboys would be better
this year
but i expected it to be
close to a double-digit win i expected
it to be
not hanging in the balance
like it was and you know credit to the
cowboys credit to that credit to the
game plan i mean i think they did a lot
of good things
bucks didn't look as good as i think we
all expected them to look coming back
with all the starters you expected them
to pick up where they left off they were
they were a little uh
you know they they were all over the
place
if you're a cowboys fan today how do you
feel
i think you feel pretty good um you know
moral victories we always talk about
them or say that that's that's not
really a thing in the nfl because it's
about winning football games
but i just said what i expected to
happen last night and the cowboys took
them down to the wire the cowboys had
opportunities they made some mistakes
otherwise man they could have been in
had this game in hand a lot earlier but
i think the biggest thing is is that
prescott you know you're coming back
from the injury we wondered what we were
going to get you just signed him to the
big deal you know some people were still
wondering is he a franchise guy can he
carry this team with his right arm
he answered all of those questions last
night
you know i think what they can be what
they want to be that they want to be a
throw first team which is what the nfl
has gone to and dak showed him we can do
this and the defense stepped up and made
some plays when they needed to still i
don't know if it's a championship
defense yet but if you've got an offense
that can play like that and dak plays
like that consistently
they're going to surprise a lot of
people and they're going to win a lot of
football games this year so i think if
you're a cowboys fan you're excited
today going yeah we went toe-to-toe with
the champs and probably should have won
that football game we're feeling pretty
good about ourselves all right more
concerned lack of a running game or the
lack of pressure on tom brady
um
i'm gonna probably say pressure
you know the lack of running game uh you
know worries me a little bit you want to
be able to run it especially because
that's what their identity was the last
couple years but what we saw last night
is what a lot of teams are starting to
do now is that it's running back by
committee and a big part of their run
game is the quick little wide receiver
screens bubble screens that you throw to
guys it's just it's become the nature of
our league um and so everybody's doing
that stuff so i expect dallas to do a
lot more of that maybe not the typical
handed off to zeke
you know run between the tackles but
yeah my concern is that again when you
play good teams and good quarterbacks
you have to get consistent pressure and
last night it was almost like
non-existent you know tom brady we all
know how great he is and the offensive
line is really really good but there was
just no consistent pressure and in
critical situations when you know they
have to throw you've got to have some
guys that can do that and they did not
and that's been kind of a theme over the
last couple years even with hank
lawrence and some of those guys up front
that you expect to be able uh to be more
consistent in that area so that to me is
probably the biggest concern
with tom brady he doesn't have
athleticism to lose i think we're
waiting to see if his arm strength is
still there and as a former quarterback
how would you assess tom brady's arm
strength yesterday last night
i mean
to me there's there's no issue there and
you know it's really what what do you
look at because i know a lot of people
look at arm strength and they say how
far can you throw it well okay if that's
what your you know barometer is we have
the hail mary at the end of the half
where he throws it a good 60 yards
launches it up in the air no problem you
barely need to throw it more than 60
yards in a game at any point in time but
to me when i look at arm strength i look
at the ability to
uh you know throw from a to b and i
always use the term firm but soft you
know the ability to put enough on the
ball that it gets there quickly but also
the touch to put it where it needs to be
and make it uh available for your
receivers and we saw that over and over
and over again last night with tom brady
uh he can throw the go route he could
throw those balls down to feel the
touchdown to a b
no issues with
how far he can throw it but to me to see
other stuff is that there's zip on the
ball the ball is getting there when it
needs to get there so i mean i know we
continue to talk about it dan and i'm
i'm with you is that he plays the game a
certain way and he always has that isn't
just going to fall off a shelf and all
of a sudden he can't play with his mind
and he can't play with timing
and i believe he's always going to have
enough arm strength to be able to play
this game as long as he's got that power
behind it and so to me he looked as good
as ever last night and uh you know just
i know we're all amazed by it but
i just expect it every time now is that
he keeps himself in great shape and you
see that every time he steps on the
field
but explain to us
that that window that you have and how
how quickly that window closes when when
you're back there trying to process all
of this and you can see something but
you got to make it happen
explain that process in your mind
well i mean the process the idea is just
knowing ahead of time
what you're going to do and you know
that is the difference between guys like
tom brady and these young guys that are
extremely talented and they have these
unbelievable arms they do all of this
stuff
tom brady can process and see things
beforehand
know and have a really good idea on what
he's going to do after the snap and
that's the whole game and especially
when you get older is that it's about
being able to know
okay i know what i'm going to get here
all i've got to do is peek this guy if
he turns his shoulders that way i'm
throwing it out here he turns his
shoulders this way i'm throwing it back
inside and a guy like tom brady watching
him process that information and know
you know we always talk about this with
quarterbacks right you're not going to
show tom brady something he hasn't seen
before well
that's just a relative term because it
all comes down to what you see
in that moment but he's so good at
knowing who do i look at what defender
do i read on this particular play and if
you can simplify the game and you don't
have to know where 11 guys are at all
times you need to know where one or two
guys are at all times and if you know
which one or two guys that is on a play
it makes the game easier and you can
just process and get to the guy that you
want to and tom brady again is you know
the best of a lot of different things
but he's the best in the business of
being able to see those things and
process them so quickly so he can do the
right thing with the football
you were 28 i think when you made your
first nfl start
yes sir
now
zach wilson's 21
what would you have been like at 21 in
the nfl as opposed to 28
i don't know um you know and i look at
zach wilson because you know zach wilson
i guess played a couple years in college
i i played one year uh in college when i
was on the field playing as a full-time
starter and i realized from the time i
was you know that age or maybe even a
little older when i when i graduated to
the time i came back in the nfl how much
football i learned uh you know how much
i grew how much situational stuff
playing arena football and in europe i
got to experience that i hadn't
experienced that one year playing ball
yeah yeah i played well zach wilson
played great uh you know last year but
there's so many things that that you you
think you have to grow through and you
have to understand and so you know these
guys are ahead of the game they do all
the seven on sevens and they throw the
ball a lot more and see a lot more
situations but that to me is is what you
look for with a young guy is how do they
handle
all these things that are going to be
thrown at them you know not the least of
it as being an nfl starting quarterback
in new york and the scrutiny and
pressure and expectation that comes with
that so i don't know if i would have
been very good when i was 21 years old
i'm fortunate that i got seasoned a
little bit through that time and when i
got to be 28 i was much more mature in
who i was as a player and who i was as a
person to be able to deal with all the
stuff that comes with it we're talking
to kurt warner the hall of famer nfl
network analyst he was on the call on
westwood one last night with kevin
harlan yeah trying to understand these
quarterbacks and i know that they grew
up in a different era as far as being
acclimated to five wide when you're in
high school calling your own plays at
the
line of scrimmage private coaches all of
these things but
you know trevor lawrence is on a team
that's not very good whereas mac jones
is on a team that i think will be a
playoff team the difference in those two
situations
is what the biggest part of that is bad
team quarterback good team rookie
quarterback
i think the biggest challenge is not
feeling like you have to do everything
is if you're in a situation like mac
jones and you say to yourself man we can
run the ball or we can scheme guys or
our defense we know bill belichick is
always going to have a good defense and
not allow a bunch of points each and
every game
it helps you to settle in and go okay i
know there's expectations because i was
a number one draft pick or the number
one overall pick
but i don't have to do everything on my
own and that's going to you know
implement itself you're going to see
that play out you know if you're trevor
lawrence coming in and you don't have
that defense and you're the number one
pick and everybody expects you to be you
know you hear all these things oh he's
the best prospects of peyton manning or
or these things that you hear
and now your team's not very good and
you're expected to win and make a
difference
i think it's so much easier to start
pressing and going okay i got to make
every throw i gotta i've gotta do
everything for this team i can't ever
throw the ball away i've gotta run
around and make these special plays to
be a difference maker for my team
and oftentimes that can take you in the
wrong direction especially if you're not
made up the right way where you're going
to go through lumps and you're going to
throw a bunch of interceptions because
you're trying to do too much so that's
something i'm always watching with every
rookie quarterback but specifically in
situations where a guy is drafted that
high and the team around him isn't that
good yet the expectation is for that
young man to come in and make an
immediate difference no matter who's
around
it's great to talk to you i know you had
a busy schedule getting back home and uh
we appreciate you joining us kurt thank
you
you got it dan we'll talk soon that's
kurt warner hall of famer joining us on
behalf of the nfl network in westwood
one